okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel
today i'm going to be doing like a
little bit different like less edited
format so let me know if you like this
format if you don't
um but i wanted to give like a couple
thoughts
on how to go up on
what like kevin samuels talks about and
what i disagree with him on
so when it's interesting to me listening
to kevin samuels because
my i grew up in like the family that
like they
talk about um like the ideal high value
man
as like my dad i guess and
uh like i have nine siblings so it's
like
can we live in like a giant mansion and
it's interesting because a lot of the
stuff
that he talks about is somewhat like
foreign to me
or at least it was when i started
watching his videos i've watched them
for a while now
in specific like specifically
to cheating now
i'm not gonna deny the fact like
obviously
if you give people more people the
option to cheat
more people are gonna do it right that's
that's just like common sense like
in general people cheat right obviously
if you have more opportunities
you're more likely to do it but it's
just
weird to me because when i grew up like
my dad was never like that like
he didn't drink never went out um
there was no like weird stuff like that
and i know
here's a problem with the manosphere
okay because the nanosphere will tell me
that he like did do all that stuff i
just didn't know and
i'm not saying it's not possible but if
you guys met my dad and i want to
introduce you guys to my dad
but he doesn't like social media but
exactly that like
he's the type of guy that
like he doesn't like social media he
doesn't like people he's never drank in
his life
he met married my mom young right
started a family with her young done
with the same woman his whole life
and i think like nowadays
you see less and less and less than that
um and
that's for a couple reasons i'm gonna be
going on a couple tantrums this is how i
talk
take it or leave it but there's a couple
of reasons for that one of them being
like social media obviously like social
media gives you more opportunity to
cheat
right like that so i think like more
people
take you up on that women like have the
option to get divorced nowadays
and like honestly there's a lot of
unhappy single people that i think
encourage
people to get out of marriages that like
they really should be able to work
through just like
from watching but i think the lifestyle
and the culture that
kevin samuels like talks about like the
high value lifestyle
is like there's two types of
millionaires there's people that worked
in corporate america
and like climb their way up the
corporate ladder for a really long time
and then there's people that
own a small business grew that small
business sold the small business
and they
they ended up like getting rich that way
does that make sense
i don't know if it makes i'm half paying
attention to driving half paying
attention to you guys
but the culture is like completely
different because
people that own like small businesses
are usually very like family oriented
and like very like they have
i want to say more values but like
they're not in situations
as often that like allow them to cheat
or like
push them to cheat and i think a lot of
people cheat because
of like situations that they put
themselves in
um so i don't know if that's like a
disagreement or what but
it's just interesting because like this
like lavish lifestyle that kevin samuels
talks about
isn't really the reality for like my
family
um or like even the richest like people
i know like one of the richest
people that i know actually like
lives like very modestly and because
they understand like
that that money is for their like their
future like their kids
so i don't
sorry i'm i said where i disagree with
kevin samuels but the more i think about
it like
i think i'm more saying like a
difference that i've noticed when it
comes to like the cheating stuff
is i don't see it as much
in like the small business circles as
you see in like corporate america
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or you disagree i know half you
guys
will say i'm like delusional which is
fine but i'll talk to you guys later